begin this morning with a new and
dangerous chapter in the pandemic
alarming concerns about the sharp
increase in the number of covit cases in
the u.s
for the first time since january
infections are up in all states
some of the most populous countries are
counties in california we should say
are returning to indoor mass mandates
this as new cases over the past week
surged 69 percent hospitalizations are
up 36 percent
and deaths have increased 26 percent
the centers for disease control says
unvaccinated americans are driving these
numbers
accounting for nearly all deaths in
almost all of the hospitalizations
michael george is here with the latest
michael what more can you tell us
well good morning michelle the rise in
cases is giving new urgency to efforts
to get people
vaccinated especially because half of
all new cases
are from the fast spreading delta
variant in some places safety mandates
that were rolled back just a month ago
are now being reinstated starting
tonight
masks will be required to be worn
indoors in los angeles county for anyone
unvaccinated or vaccinated the new case
count has hit
1 000 a day doubling this week
mostly among people who have not taken
the shot i don't like it
i'm vaccinated i wish everybody else
would get vaccinated
it's a sentiment echoed far and wide
five unvaccinated indiana nursing home
residents
were among coronavirus victims this week
when the nation passed
34 million cumulative cases
now average daily cases have more than
doubled in the last two weeks
with the rate of cases highest in states
where less than half of the people
are fully vaccinated there is a clear
message that is
coming through this is becoming a
pandemic
of the unvaccinated we are seeing
outbreaks of cases in parts of the
country that have low vaccination
coverage
because unvaccinated people are at risk
the president added a hard punch at the
lies by anti-vaxxers running rampant on
social media
they're killing people i mean it really
they'll look the only pandemic we have
is among the unvaccinated
and that and they're killing people in a
statement facebook defended its part
saying more than 3.3 million americans
have also used our vaccine finder tool
to find out where and how to get a
vaccine the facts show
facebook is helping save lives but
there's also
this fact 99.5 percent
of all the debts to covid are in
unvaccinated people
that's a very very striking statistic
that should get people to appreciate why
it's so important to get vaccinated
and doctors say vaccinated people do
have a strong level of protection
against the delta variant but as we've
been hearing from the beginning
masks are still important to stop the
spread of the virus to other people
okay michael thank you very much